Day after day, the green grasshopper grazed.
Most of the time, Grasshopper grazed on green leaves.
Sometimes, he grazed on grass.
But Grasshopper was tired of grazing on green leaves and grass.
"I'm going to eat new food today," he said.
Then, he hopped into the forest.
Grasshopper grinned when he saw all the new food to eat.
"Maybe these green berries will taste great," said Grasshopper.
"Gross!" he groaned.
He hopped to find something else to eat.
"Maybe these gray nuts will taste great," said Grasshopper.
"Gross!" he groaned, hopping on.
"Maybe this sweet honey will taste great," said Grasshopper.
"Gross!" he groaned.
"I'm hopping home to graze on green leaves and grass," said the grumpy grasshopper.
At home, Grasshopper greeted his friends.
He said, "I just ate berries, nuts, and honey."
"Those foods aren't great for grasshoppers like me.
They're gross!" he said.
His friends said, "Don't you know?
Green leaves and grass are the greatest foods for grasshoppers."
"Be glad you are a grasshopper!" they said.
Now Grasshopper always grins as he grazes on green leaves and grass.